- Hi.
Welcome everybody.
If you are looking for
closing the gap between
shipping and safety
shipping faster at scale,
you're in the right place.
So thank you for coming.
It is 9:00 AM in Las Vegas,
which is either noon if
you're from the West coast,
or 6:00 AM if you're on Vegas time.
So thank you all very much for coming.
I'm Edith Harbaugh.
I am CEO and co-founder of LaunchDarkly.
And with me today I have
Jeffrey Goldberg of Qlik
and Nate Gray, Ally,
and do you wanna give a
brief intro of both of you
and your roles before we get going?
- Sure, I'll go first.
Nate Gray, Ally Financial, Ally Bank.
You might have seen the commercials.
We're the largest digital
bank in the country.
I am over digital engineering operations,
so primarily customer facing applications
and the APIs that interact with them.
- And I'm Jeff Goldberg, I, whoa,
and I work at Qlik.
We're a data integration
analytics and AI software company.
And I am a product manager responsible for
a number of different
areas in the platform.
And I help our developers with tools,
bringing in tools that help
them with their productivity.
- So I'm gonna give a very
brief overview of LaunchDarkly.
This is not meant to be a vendor talk,
it's meant to be them discussing software.
But I want to give a
little level set about
what LaunchDarkly does.
So I started LaunchDarkly
in 2014 as the founder.
And the reason why I started it,
is because I kept feeling the
same pain over and over again
as both an engineering manager
and then as a product manager,
which was that releases are hard.
You know, back then we did
a release once a quarter
and every time there's
so much anxiety around,
is it gonna go out okay?
You know, 'cause back then
build pipelines where (indistinct),
and then even beyond that, after you ship,
is it gonna fall over and go thud?
Basically, you know,
the fingers crossed I
test a lot in a server
that was in production.
I tested a sandbox, but now
it's in live in production,
is it actually gonna work?
And then work has a lot
of different definitions.
After you push it, is it actually
delivering business value?
You know, something could be working fine,
but customers hate it.
So from all that, I came up
with the idea for LaunchDarkly,
which is basically a runtime
control plane for features
where you can launch measure
and control features after,
so you can launch them and
then measure and control them.
From that over the last 10 years,
we've continued to expand on what it means
to be a feature management platform.
So now LaunchDarkly allows
you to release something,
it allows you to observe it
and allows you to iterate with it,
with our experimentation engine.
And we do all this via
a base of 20 plus SDEKs.
If you are using a language,
we probably have it.
And if we don't have an SDK for it,
it is probably something like COBOL
where we cannot physically do it.
But anything else that
you want, we have it.
Set top boxes, devices,
we have an SDK for it.
And the goal of all this is
to de-risk every release.
You know, as a former,
as I said before, as a product manager
and engineering manager,
when something goes wrong,
you feel it very viscerally
that something has gone wrong,
it's bad in the field.
And even more than that,
that under stress that you have to fix it.
So if something goes wrong,
you have this panic
feeling due to cortisol
and that is actually the
worst time to make a decision.
Some of the worst releases
I've had happen is,
when something goes bad
and then there's this panic moment of
what version do you roll back to?
How do we roll it back?
And suddenly you're trying
to roll forward or roll back
and cherry pick
and you somehow end up in
a worse mess than before.
So our goal is to de-risk every release
by allowing you to do self
rollbacks at (indistinct)
and also to allow you some new features
we've built over the last 10 years
to allow you to accelerate AI development.
Because with this ability
to do quick rollbacks
and girded releases,
you can have a lot more
confidence in what you're doing.
As well we can help you
experiment after it is released.
So if you have functionality
that you wanna see
whether people like different
AM models differently,
you can test that out.
And all this happily
coincides very nicely with,
not just developer productivity,
but developer happiness.
This is a big goal of mine.
You know, if you have confidence
that things that you ship,
if something goes wrong,
you could quickly iterate on them,
it's a lot easier to ship.
If you have stress and anxiety about,
oh, is this gonna work,
is it's not gonna work?
That's what I think that
development really slows down,
'cause then suddenly you
have a lot of meetings
or conference calls about
how confident are we,
which is his own operational drag.
So that's a brief
overview of LaunchDarkly.
Now I'm really gonna turn it over
to a group discussion about
the gap between speed and reliability.
I'd say for a while this was seen
as a false dichotomy in my mind
that you could either go
fast in the Facebook model
of ship everything, break
everything, who cares.
Or I'd say the slow and steady
of let's ship once a quarter
and really make sure it's right.
And the reason why I feel like
this was a false dichotomy
is because if you have
a quarterly release,
it's actually more likely
that something goes wrong
because you have so many fixes,
so many things working together
that it's much more likely that
something will break With
all this combination.
I feel like if you ship more frequently
with smaller units of value,
it's a lot easier to
isolate what's happening
and that it's actually much easier
to get more reliable software.
My joke is, you know,
so I used to be a big time runner
and the joke is that, you know,
you go to the doctor and your knee hurts
and they say, well, you know,
if your knee hurts, stop running.
If you're a software development company
and your releases are always broken,
you can't just stop shipping.
It's not a valid answer to say,
hey, whenever we're
not gonna ship anymore,
'cause all our releases are terrible.
The the right answer is
let's keep doing this
until every release is easy and reliable.
So I have a couple questions for panelists
just to get started
and I'll ask you both to answer this one.
How do you feel like cadence has changed
in your own orgs over the last 10 years?
Like, how have you bridged this gap
between speed and reliability?
- I'll go first. Yeah, sure.
So we've moved from an on-premises product
to the cloud,
and I think that that has been a key point
of moving from those quarterly releases,
or we were releasing
software five times a year
for an on-premises product,
to now just continuous
delivery of features of bugs.
And that really transformed
the development organization.
It really became something
where the developers
were really very happy
because they were just constantly,
they were feeling like they
were able to achieve velocity.
They were able to go ahead
and just keep moving, keep progressing
in different iterations of the software
that they were delivering.
It's interesting though
that now we're, you know,
five or six years into our cloud journey,
and we have some desire to
offer certain capabilities
from a continuous perspective,
but then there are other
features that we wanna hold back.
But it's not necessarily
because of any sort of
like engineering drag
or anything like that.
It's more about marketing
and the integration of product marketing
and thinking about how release
is now more about moments
in addition to being able to
push and ship more frequently.
So it's coming up with that balance
that we're working on right now.
- Yeah, that's a pretty common pattern of
sometimes there's a reason why
customers don't wanna
see something, right?
Then like if you're doing a big promotion
around Black Friday,
you don't wanna show it in August.
- Right.
Right, exactly.
And for us, we have large
enterprise customers that will,
what they like to do is they like to
essentially preview features
before they're released.
They like to do things like
build their own documentation,
even though we have documentation,
they like to build their own enablement.
So what we're beginning
to offer in the new year,
is a way for customers to
configure their tenants
through just a toggling capability,
a different release channel
that they want to have
their tenants release
or receive different features.
So items that would be on a monthly
or a quarterly release
will be determined by product management,
product marketing and the engineering team
in collaboration with one another.
And they'll go ahead
and they'll set up the
targeting rules to set that up.
But if your tenant is
set up for continuous,
you'll actually get those
features as they ship.
And that gives the customer
a lot more confidence
because they can control
how they distribute and
allow their end users
to consume these new capabilities
with better support
models from their side.
- And are your developers happier now
because they can decouple
release from deployment?
- I think that's still, you know,
something that is where there's some,
still some growth opportunity.
I think we've been in a centralized model
for release management
for such a long time
because even though we moved to the cloud,
we still maintain more of
that on-premises mindset
of release.
But now we have close to 400 developers
and engineers that have access
to toggle feature flags in production.
And so we've decentralized
and given the development
teams more control,
they're gaining more confidence.
Because they have that capability,
they're more thoughtful
about when flags get toggled.
And so we've seen incidents go down
and that helps raise
their confidence as well.
Coming back to your point of
do we need to have these
gates in these meetings
to feel like we're confident,
now they have the wherewithal
to have more control over that
and take action
if they see anything that
doesn't look right immediately.
- How about you?
- Yeah, developer happiness
has been a key driver of our
tech modernization actually.
I wrote a blog post on
Ally Tech blog about
how Ally got our nights and
weekends back, you know,
we were doing the quarterly
releases then monthly releases,
but they were always middle
of the weekend, right?
For a bank, if someone
can't log in to check their,
you know, check their
account or transfer money
or pay a bill, that's a really big deal.
So like we can't cause customer impact,
but also engineers
can't work 45 hour weeks
and nights and weekends.
So what's the solution?
Yeah, LaunchDarkly was a big part of that
through feature flags.
So now we do, we went from, I say monthly,
but it was monthly
releases plus, you know,
a handful of hot fixes
that obviously are always
rushed out and ill tested,
to this year we're averaging
68 releases a month
across about 15 applications.
We feature flag every UI change.
We do API first development,
so the API, we've separated
APIs from UI deployments,
separated releases from deployments,
APIs go in for the UIs.
We then target, you know,
the new version of the
API with phased roll-outs.
First we do customer
pilot or employee pilot.
So testing in production,
everyone says, don't test in production.
No, please do test in production.
That's the only way you can actually test
what's happening in production, right?
So create segments for
our internal pilot team,
then 1% roll-out to customers,
5% roll-out up to, you know,
up to a hundred percent
as long as all the metrics are tracking.
- That's great.
Like what changes have
you felt in your own team
with getting their
nights and weekends back?
- Yeah, I mean,
I'm a father of two boys
that keep me very busy
and, you know,
I preach work-life balance to my team,
it's really important to me.
I have the benefit of having
leadership that agrees with that.
And so we can ship at 5:00 PM
as soon as the stock market closes
because we have the confidence that
we know before we're
gonna break something.
We can, you know, we
can back out that pilot
even if we do cause customer impact,
it's not a 30 minute pipeline deployment,
it's a 32nd, you know, flag flip.
So it's improved developer
satisfaction tremendously.
- What changes have you
felt in your own team
with the change in cadence?
- I think, you know, from our developers,
they really like that they
have that flexibility.
But I think one thing
that you were just saying
the separation of deployment
and release is really where
they feel more comfort.
I think that there was such
a tight coupling before,
now there's this confidence
that they can deploy.
They can just continuously
deploy as long as they have,
they've set up their flags
to basically deploy dark into
those production environments.
And then they're able to very, you know,
very granularly turn on,
whether it's through a phase
roll-out, or release pipeline,
or using guarded roll-outs.
We just implemented guarded roll-outs
in the last couple of weeks,
so we were just starting
our enablement there.
But in terms of the functionality
of using different targeting rules,
it's really interesting to see
the maturity of the
teams as they go through
and they work through those things.
They've really started to,
and I guess enjoy being able to say,
oh, I put it on this tenant,
so gonna invite you to this tenant
that I have internally,
so that you can go ahead
and take a look at it.
We have some announcements this week,
and those we're doing
some private previews,
so we're working with, you know,
there's a, again, a collaboration between
the dev management team
and product management to
establish different segments
for those different
previews that we will do
throughout the journey to a
generally available product.
And it's just wonderful to know that
we can keep delivering that
software into production
with aspects of it still turned off
because we can be super granular with
how many flags we wanna have,
how we bring the flags together
from a prerequisite perspective.
And we also tie it in
with access control too.
So we on the back end and the front end
so that we can make sure
that when we do release,
we're not only releasing just a UI change,
but we're implementing the access control
that goes along with it
and it's really looking
at the full feature
across multiple flags,
it seems like that kind
of granular control.
- Where do you feel
that there's still risk?
Like what are some
non-negotiable guardrails?
And this is for both of you.
- For us in a, you know,
we're a highly regulated industry.
You know, auditors and regulators
are regularly checking that
every GitLab production tag
aligns to an approved CR
with test evidence and scans
are all done appropriately.
And so it's regulatory
and compliance risk is a big one for us,
making sure that we're doing
everything by the book.
And then, you know, resiliency,
being able to instantly know
if you're causing trouble
and flip that flag back.
- In our world we have
two different pieces.
We're FedRAMP compliant product.
So we have to sometimes separate
what is released in our
commercial environment
and stage that release before
we're allowed to bring that
into the federal environment
for the purposes of audit.
We have to go through audit processes
and that sort of thing
from a significant change perspective.
So that's one non-negotiable piece.
And we make sure that there's
that separation of duties
and that there's the people who can access
the FedRAMP environment,
have a mechanism to turn on
and set up the flags in the right way.
And then I think one
of the other, you know,
things that we've been able to do
because of our decentralization
of the teams really owning their releases
and owning their feature flags now is,
really being confident
before you turn a flag on
for right default.
Default true is not the way
that you start working on a flag,
you start with default false
and you protect yourself
using the targeting rules
as a guardrail.
So those are some of the pretty,
I guess, light non-negotiable
pieces on our commercial side
because we've been so
restrictive in the past
that's actually caused more incidents
than it's actually prevented.
- Can you tell us a little bit more about
how has being too cautious
caused an incident, if you can?
- Well, yeah. So again,
it comes back to something I
think I said a few minutes ago
where when we were in a,
even as we started to decentralize,
it was still kind of
like this hybrid approach
where we had a release
champions team, right?
And again, it's about having
knowledge of your feature
and someone who's a release champion
may not necessarily be in
the same domain or org,
but they're being, you know,
asked through Slack,
hey, can you flip this
on in production for me?
And they're just like,
yeah, sure, no problem.
And then all of a sudden
it's like, you know,
support calls start coming in, you know,
errors start flowing through into Splunk
and everybody, you know, you get,
all of a sudden you have
250 people jumping into
an incident channel in Slack.
Now that the ownership has
fully shifted to the dev teams,
they don't have to ask
anyone for permission.
They are in control.
We treat our developers like
adults and responsible people,
and they care about that.
They don't want incidents,
they want their,
they wanna make sure that their code
works properly in production.
So this level of control just
automatically solves the,
it solves the problem
itself, it solves itself.
- It definitely felt that, you know,
I got into engineering because
I liked building things.
- Yep.
- And when we had, you know,
I'm old enough that we used
to have like annual releases,
that's just really painful, you know?
'Cause you're working on something
and sometimes by the time it's
ready to ship, it's obsolete.
But if you can release
once a week or once a day,
you get this little,
you know, kick of joy of
well, A, there are people using it.
And also if they're not gonna use it,
I at least know that sooner.
- Yep.
- You know?
- Well this is the next phase for us,
is really getting into,
as I was mentioning,
the private preview that we're doing
for some of the new features
that we have coming out soon
and getting into more experiments.
So we've turned on all of
that observability parts.
We're engaging our design team
to facilitate more experimentation
through LaunchDarkly.
We're building out capabilities
that allow our customers
to opt into betas and previews
and different parts of our release model,
so that we can get feedback earlier,
so that we can actually
put something out there,
that I think you were saying it
at the beginning of the
call where, you know,
you think that the meta approach
where you're throwing something out there
and just let it break is bad.
It's not that it's bad
per se, it's a choice.
It's how you control that decision.
And that's the exciting part
about using LaunchDarkly
is it gives you so many
different opportunities to,
and control, not in a negative sense,
but control in a positive sense.
The feedback loops that you establish,
whether they're customer driven,
where the user's opting in
or they're experiments that we wanna run,
whether it's AB testing
or doing something where we
allow our customers, you know,
operate in a canary mode or
do blue-green deployment.
That flexibility for our development teams
and for our design teams
and our product management teams
just enables better quality
outcomes for our customers.
We will end up shipping lovable,
like not to use the company's name,
but you know, the lovable and features
that our customers crave
and they look forward to.
- I mean, that's what we're
all here for is I think is,
you know, it's fun to see, you know,
bits and bytes turn into real experiences.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Along with that, you know,
I have to ask this 2025,
how are you approaching AI
and how it plays into
your own release cycles
and your own software development?
And either you can.
- We treat models like features.
So, you know, our enterprise AI team is,
we have a employee front end
for like a ChatGPT type experience
that is a hundred percent feature flags.
And then for the AI configs models,
being treated like
features and phase roll-out
and measured just like any
other customer feature would be.
- In our platform where our customers
are ingesting a lot of data into it.
And then either running that
through transformation
pipelines and analytics,
and then we have the capability
to build out assistance
that you can deploy out into
and embed into other ecosystems.
What we need to be thoughtful about
is how our customers
want to treat that data
and where they want that data to go.
So being able to give them the opportunity
to control the artificial
intelligence capabilities
of where they can pull data
from is really important.
So like, I'm not gonna,
I'm not an AI expert,
but criss-cross region
inference I think is something that
has become really
important for our platform
as our customers have data residency
and sovereignty concerns.
So we are offering a way
for our customers to use
different versions of our AI platform
based on a toggle that they flip that
calls a LaunchDarkly API,
adds them to a segment and
then enables that feature,
allows them to start
using that cross reference
or cross region technology,
so that they can enrich their AI products.
And it's, again, it's just
that kind of integration
is really great to
provide to our customers
as a way that they can control
a certain set of features
for those types of use cases.
And that's how we're
enabling AI capabilities
alongside what you were saying
just from like a feature
functionality perspective.
- And ironically, our head of AI
was a LaunchDarkly user
in his previous role
that we acquired that company.
And so he already came over
asking for feature flags.
- Which company was that?
- It was, I knew you were gonna ask that.
- Oh, I felt like I should
know it and I don't.
- Yeah. It was a point
of sale lending company.
- I think I know, yeah.
- Okay.
- Well, I guess I stated
at the beginning that,
I feel like there isn't really a choice
between speed and reliability.
I guess to put it back to you two,
do you feel like going faster
has made your software more reliable?
Or what do you still struggle with
or think about in your own processes?
- There's still, I mean,
going faster brings new
complexities, new challenges, right?
I mean, we broke our monolith
APIs into microservices.
We broke our web architecture
into a micro front end.
And so there's a lot more moving pieces,
but they can all be
independently deployable.
So giving that freedom to,
we have a rule that
essentially everything,
every application, every deployment
has to be independently deployable.
And so that's how we've
managed that new complexity
that came with moving faster
is getting rid of dependencies
everywhere we can.
- That's smart.
Was it hard to go through
that process? Did you-
- There were certainly
some learning, yeah,
some lessons learned throughout the way.
Some, you know, I'm not gonna lie and say
we didn't take down production or twice,
but I think everybody here
probably has done that.
- For us, the reliability piece
is really important because of, again,
the just the feeds and speeds of the data
and the way that our customers use data
to take decisions every day.
So what we've been trying to do, again,
to help the developers have
a greater level of control
is using context and making sure that
the full product set is
context aware of the user
or of the tenant,
or specific services that are in place.
So one of the things
that we've implemented
when we see a degradation
of a particular service
from a reliability perspective is,
we've created a string based feature flag
that our SRE team can go in
and toggle a debug mode
for a specific tenant.
And so now they can actually,
so they can identify the support,
will identify a customer
that's having an issue,
they'll supply the tenant ID,
the SRE will go in
or the dev team will go in,
they'll add the targeting
to that specific tenant,
turn on debug mode.
And now that will change the
logs that come into Splunk,
so that they can actually do
more of a forensic analysis
of what's actually happening
across the services
that they're using, so.
- But only for that customer.
- But only for that customer,
only for that tenant.
So like we have OEM products,
so we have customers that
have thousands of tenants
in production as end customers
of their SaaS solution
- Yeah.
- are embedding analytics.
So being able to trace that
and have that level of control,
that drives reliability.
So I kind of feel like
your question about speed
and reliability, yes, they
kind of go hand in hand,
but what we've been able to do
is actually decouple it, right?
We use the platform to drive
those use cases separately.
Reliability in terms of
like the shipping faster
just comes from what
we've been talking about
relative to the access
and the control that the
developers have of their features.
But this piece really helps us
shortcut any sort of like real digging
into any code to really
understand what a problem is
because we can just turn
that on and turn that off
as needed to identify problems.
And that reliability is really great.
And then what we can do is, again,
through segments is we
can control regionally
what things are happening.
So if it's isolated to a specific region,
because even though you're in production,
we're in 15 different regions, you know,
ghosts in the machine, they happen,
you can basically set things up,
so that as you're fixing problems,
you can isolate down.
And that's where the context
piece really, really helps
and shines with reliability.
- Yeah. So LaunchDarkly is actually
a big customer of LaunchDarkly.
So we serve trillions
of features every day
and we do a lot of interesting stuff.
People think of us as just
serving features to users.
A user can be a machine,
a user can be an API,
so we can really dive in
and if, you know, we're
getting session calls
that are not good, we can, you know,
block an IP block an API
and do that very quickly.
- Yes. Yeah.
And I think, you know,
to log roll a little bit
on the LaunchDarkly part,
I see that not only from
that ability to isolate
because of context,
but that also percolates into
just the usability features
from an administration perspective.
So as the effectively the
product owner for LaunchDarkly,
I take a look at like authorization
and how roles and teams are set up.
And what I love is the granular
way that we can scope
machine tokens or users
and they're actually born from the same
access control model.
And that is,
especially with what we're
doing in the release cadence
and with the criss
toggle that I mentioned,
we have basically just
instead of, you know,
having a an API token
that can basically do a
whole bunch of things,
it literally can touch those two segments.
It can write to those two
segments and that's it.
That level of granularity
and control is just,
it's fantastic.
- Yeah. We have a lot of people
who use us for device management.
For example, you know,
if you know that it's not gonna work
on this version of Android, just block it.
- Yeah.
- Don't have
a bad user experience.
- Yeah. Yeah. It's very cool.
- What are you thinking about in terms of
where you want your
release processes to go?
I mean, it seems like you both
are pretty forward looking.
Is there things that are
still on your roadmap
or do you feel like you
are in a good steady state?
- Yeah, automation.
I don't know what,
I don't know what automation
really looks like, right?
I mean, I know we want it.
I know the more automation the better.
I know that the automation we've put in
has made significant improvements.
But in a regulated industry,
I don't know that we'll
ever get to like, you know,
one button full automation.
There's gotta be some human
in the loop along the way,
but automating as much of
the pipeline as possible,
automating testing.
The difficult part for us with
production validations is,
when you're validating in production,
it's a real bank account, right?
Like our developers are
logging in on release calls
to their personal account and you know,
moving money and purchasing shares.
And that's really the
only way we can do it.
There's a team that
was supporting auto payments
that for a time they didn't
have anyone on the team
that had an auto loan through Ally.
So they would've to ask for volunteers
to come validate.
So production validations are,
have always been a challenge.
Anything we can do to
automate that, you know,
that's where we want to go.
- Yeah. It's it's so true.
I mean, I don't, I bank like anybody else.
I want the number to be right.
- Right. Exactly.
- Yeah.
Automation, I completely
agree with what you're saying.
The ability for our
developers to be able to,
and this is where I see
like guarded roll-outs
and some of the other
capabilities coming into play,
that automation.
And then allowing our customers to choose
in certain cases,
so that our developers are
focused on shipping features,
not necessarily getting calls to say,
hey, can you toggle this on
for this particular tenant?
They wanna try this out, right?
Because, you know, we're in the middle of
an engagement or something like that.
So being able to support those
types of use cases is huge.
And that's where the automation comes in.
The tighter integration
with the products set.
And then just giving the developers
the opportunity to work through
the experimentation processes
and have that trigger different workflows
either inside or outside of LaunchDarkly,
I think is another way for them to
accelerate their workflow from
a development perspective.
- Yeah. A big change I myself have seen
over the next 10 years
is just the acceptance
that automation is good.
So, you know, when I started
the company 10 years ago
when I talked to prospects about,
hey, you can move stuff through stages,
like the examples you gave.
- Yep.
- And I would ask,
do you wanna have this automated?
They would say, absolutely not.
You know, somebody needs
to flip that switch.
I need somebody to flip it.
But what's changed, I
think AI has accelerated,
is people are like,
actually a machine could
flip it faster than a human.
And in fact, I do not
wanna wait for a human,
like, you know, we have a customer
that does payment processing,
they're like, if something's going wrong,
I wanna stop it within a second.
- Oh yeah.
- I don't wanna wait
for somebody to get paged five minutes.
Like I want a second.
And then the person get paged,
they could figure out why it went wrong.
But I don't want that delay.
- I think you're absolutely right.
Like it's an,
I can't presume what, you
know, what developers want.
But as someone who's always
aspired to be a developer,
I really embrace automation
because if I can not have to worry about
that kind of concern,
and I can continue to focus on building,
that's the part of the
job that I really enjoy.
So to be able to automate
that, either get an alert
or what have you so that,
or have it automatically roll back,
it's just like, that's great,
'cause I don't have to,
I'm gonna say context
in two different ways.
I don't have to context switch
from being in builder mode
to being in fix it mode, right?
But then,
what you're mentioning
from an AI perspective,
which is so important is that,
it's all about context.
That is what,
if you give your agents,
you give your AI the
context of what you want,
you give it, you provide
the instructions on
how to behave when you
see certain conditions,
it will go ahead and handle that for you.
And that you can provide that
in a natural language way
versus like, dragging and dropping blocks,
I think is what makes
it way more approachable
for a developer now than
it did maybe, you know,
even three to five years ago
where it was like, oh, use Workato.
Like, sorry Workato folks.
It's a great tool, but you know,
where you're dragging and dropping blocks.
I mean, we have that
capability in our platform
with like click automate,
but our customers want to
be able to just, you know,
be like Scotty in "Star Trek
Four" and say hello computer,
and out comes transparent aluminum.
- Anything to add?
- So we've shifted left
on security scanning,
which has prevented a lot
of last minute fire drills.
So, you know, implementing security gating
at the point of, you know,
that first merge request means, you know,
we're not waiting on a
weekly scan to come in
right before the release sign-offs.
The developers have much more control
over the timing of those releases.
And then by having everything
independently releasable
and feature flagable,
if something comes up,
that component just
doesn't go that release.
And so we don't have to back out code
at any point in process.
We just, you know, decide
not to flip that feature
or deploy that microservice.
- Hearing you talk about that again,
makes me remember the way we
used to develop a decade ago.
And I don't want to go back. (laughs)
- No, no.
Actually, so the first
time we used a feature flag
from LaunchDarkly,
it was the second week of COVID.
And the feature that
we'd been working on for
a month or so was an annual
employment verification
for customers,
that certain products require
annual employment verification.
Well, when half the world
was being, you know,
laid off and fired,
that's probably not the best time to ask
for employment verification.
So, but we had this big release that,
this was before we had, you know,
this is at the beginning of
our modernization journey,
but we had introduced feature flags
and that one happened to be the first one
and we just toggled it off
and everything else was able to release.
We didn't have to break
up the release package.
We didn't have to,
I mean we did some retesting,
'cause we, you know, we didn't know
what we didn't know from this new tool,
but it worked flawlessly
and then we were able to delay
that employment verification
for three months
and just toggle it on when we were ready.
- Yeah. That's the origin of our name.
That's a classic dark launch,
- Right? Yeah.
- You know, where you can
ship out features dark
and then to your metaphor default false
and then slowly turn them on.
- Yeah. Almost a hundred
percent of our UI releases
are now deployed dark,
validated by just the development teams
and product teams in production.
For mobile it's a little differently.
It's a little different because, you know,
you have to release new binaries,
push those releases out to customers
and we get negative customer feedback
when we release too fast in mobile.
People don't want to download a new app
every time they use it.
Especially, I mean,
if you're trying to
check your bank account
and you don't have
great service, you know,
you might not be able to do that
because you can't, you know,
you can't wait 20 minutes
to download a new app.
And so by being able to,
by being able to feature flag web
and mobile features together,
we can release web as often as we want,
as often as developers need to.
Mobile goes in a slower cadence,
we're about biweekly now.
And then once all the pilot
testing is done on each,
then we can flip both of
those features on together,
so that customers, regardless
of platform they're on,
see that same feature at the same time.
- That's part of the origin
story of LaunchDarkly
is I would, I was at TripIt,
which is a mobile app
and we had that exact
use case of, you know,
somebody is on the road perhaps to Vegas
and they're desperately
trying to look at something
on their phone now is not the time
- Yep.
- to ask you
to update your app.
- That's right.
- You know, and also they,
we learned the hard way that some stuff
that looked great in a mockup internally
in our user testing,
when somebody is running through
an airport, they hate it.
Like, I don't have time to
look at your beautiful UI,
just make the, you know,
make the buttons louder
and prettier is not an option,
just louder.
- Yep.
- Well, before we turn it over
to the audience, you know,
any final advice for people
on their own journeys?
Like you said you had some,
your own lessons learned,
but as people are looking to ship faster
with more reliability at the same time,
what advice would you give them?
- My advice is
bring your developers to the product.
Don't restrict their access to it.
I think that's a key
lesson that we've learned.
And provide them opportunities
to explore the paths
that they want to take to
release their products, right?
The platform itself provides
numerous different ways
to go to market.
And what I see my responsibility
from a product perspective
is to highlight what the
different features within
feature flagging can bring to bear
and show them different use cases
that they could employ when
they choose to go ahead
and release.
And that's how we will expand the maturity
and expand the confidence
that our developers will have
to use the full range and
capabilities of the product,
so that they can release more reliably.
They'll get more hands-on
experience with it
and that's what will help drive the speed.
- Yeah. Develop our autonomy.
I was gonna say that as well.
That's when we went through
our tech modernization initiative,
I laid out release
management guiding principles
and I did a road show to all
of the leadership stakeholders,
making sure that everyone's
on board with this.
And number one on that was
development teams should have the autonomy
to move at their own speed.
We are release processes
like a bus schedule.
Like you don't have to
get on every bus, right?
It there, like you're gonna have,
you have scheduled options,
you have ad hoc options
and it's up to like the release team
is supporting those
product teams to get it out
to customers.
Balancing that, you
know, speed and safety,
balancing customer service,
our customers being the
product teams we support
and you know, our risk management hats
as release management.
So giving development teams the autonomy
to move at their own speed
while putting the right
checks in place, right?
By putting the right gates in place,
the right tooling.
We do, you said that they have developers
are actually releasing
their features themselves.
But LaunchDarkly has an
approval flow built in
if you choose to use it
and we use that so the
developer builds the flag,
submits the request,
and then the release team
submits the change request,
gets that approved, approves reviews,
and approves the change
request within LaunchDarkly
and then pushes it out.
- Well I wanna conclude by saying,
I know LaunchDarkly is a vendor,
but a lot of the techniques
that we talked about today you
can use without LaunchDarkly.
So I hope you learned a lot about
how you can improve your
own development processes
and even if you're not using LaunchDarkly,
make your developer lives
happier and reduce risk.
I would like to now open it
up to questions from anybody.
We don't have a runner for the mic,
so you'll have to speak loudly
and I will ask the person in front,
'cause you sat in front.
- [Audience member] Yeah.
So my question is,
how does that tie into like, versioning?
So if you're doing,
let's say doing dark releases,
when you actually update the,
like do semantic versioning,
when would you update the release
number or the tag version?
- So we do it,
we actually don't use,
I'm sure he just doesn't
want me saying this.
We don't use feature
flags for our APIs yet.
So the UI targets the new API version.
So we'll deploy a new API version
that sits in parallel in production,
nobody's calling that yet.
And then one by one those
consumers will re-point
via a feature flag and phase roll-out
over to the new version. Does
that answer your question?
- [Audience member] I think so.
I mainly work with the platform.
So I provide pipelines for teams to build,
to push for applications.
So we increment our versioning
when every three weeks
we push out changes,
but it'd be nice to be
able to push out releases
or deploy items without team
always keep (speaking softly),
have that constant tech debt.
- So what we're looking into,
we haven't done this yet,
but as we're separating
deployment from release,
what we are looking at
is how not only would you
do a blue-green deployment,
but also like a blue-green release
where you are tying the feature
flagging to that version,
so that you can go ahead
and actually phase roll-out
from that perspective.
The other way that we do it,
the way that we do it today is we do,
I mentioned we have a
lot of different regions.
So what we've done is created
segments that have regions
of different profiles
in what we call zones.
And as part of our release
pipeline will release to zones,
we will evaluate,
make sure that things
are working properly,
and then the teams will go ahead
and continue to move those new versions
or turn those new versions of
the software on in release.
So it's really trying
to provide that one part
that is handshake.
We're again, early days there,
but there's the
functionality to support it.
And our customers are also looking for it,
like I mentioned earlier,
with respect to just the
release cadence piece
where some of our customers
want to have a tenant that's canary,
that's basically getting
like nightly updates.
So we're gonna try to figure out
how we can provide that,
so that their tenants
can run in a canary mode.
- There's a couple other techniques,
but we can take that for after.
You were just, 'cause you were persistent.
You right there. Just talk loud.
- [Audience member] Okay.
Well I have a question.
Sorry for this question, but you answer.
Yeah, okay. Are you able to hear me?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Edith, I'm really sorry for this question,
but why should I not
build my own LaunchDarkly
using AI? And like I-
- I love that question.
- Sorry.
- I love the question.
Don't apologize.
- Yeah. Okay.
So there are two parts.
What I always look for one
is like open source tools,
which will do the things
for which I'm paying
or if the open source
versions are not available,
why can't I just give Claude
or any of these tools,
like instructions to build what I want
and it'll be specific to my
deployment and my release.
So why should I not build it
and why should I look at LaunchDarkly?
- That's a great question.
And number one, the reason
why I started the company
is 'cause I think just using feature flags
is a better way to use software.
So I'll say if you have simple use cases,
a hundred percent just build it in-house.
Like if you're just like,
hey, I just need some simple on offs,
I have some very simple release processes
where I have a beta group
and a non-beta group
probably could do that yourself.
I think if you have a
more complex situation
like the ones that you just described.
- So we had our own,
we did purchase LaunchDarkly
I think back in 2020.
We were using our own feature
flag management service
because we had, you know, 15 services,
we're now 300 services and growing, right?
We're adding new services every week.
And so it's just not a concern
we want our developers to have.
So I think to your point, right,
it all depends on you reach
a certain size and scale
where you need to offload that concern.
And where all a developer has to do
is add a a few lines of
code to do an evaluation
and then all the aspects of being able
to have a finer grain control
just works for our teams,
so that they don't have
to worry about that piece.
- I know, Nate, you're
in a regulating industry,
so you might have something to add about
why not just have AI build it?
- Yeah, well we haven't
looked at specifically
that question using AI to build it,
but I was actually hanging out with guys
from Flickr last night
and they claim that they
created the first feature flag.
- Oh, MacAskill.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
- And, but they're also
LaunchDarkly customers, so like-
- That's how I know them.
- Yeah. So I said,
well clearly like there,
so they said we, you know,
we invented feature flags
and now we're paying
for this service. Why?
Because 'cause they do it better.
- I don't claim that we invented
feature flags, by the way.
Let's say that we make it easier.
- Oh, yeah.
- I just have a follow up
on that if that's okay.
So when you're saying that,
so my problem there is that,
I don't want to be vendor logged in
and then like I would want to build things
which are only specific to my deployment.
Although I understand,
well, she would have,
I mean like her company would
have much more expertise
in that area,
but we would know much more about Aztec.
So I mean, how do you measure that,
when is it good to go to a vendor
and when is it good to
build it on your own?
- I mean, I think that's
a broader question
than LaunchDarkly.
I mean we're at AWS
where I hope most people
have chosen a cloud vendor.
If you really wanna
build something yourself,
I mean that's your decision.
- Yeah. I would say if
you're a small dev team,
everyone's using the same
languages and platforms,
maybe it makes more sense
to build something in-house.
We have hundreds of dev teams
using different languages,
different platforms,
different frameworks,
and we would need an entire platform team
to support feature flagging,
which would be probably more than that,
I'm sure it would be more
than what we're paying LaunchDarkly.
- Somebody over there
had a question, I think.
- [Audience member] So my
question is trying to understand
how this works at New York company.
By the way, I'm a very big
fan of feature flagging.
So you mentioned, Nate,
that your company moved
from one release a month
to 68 releases
and my team moved from one release a month
to about 120 releases.
We just, you know, we say
just keep on shipping.
One of the problems that
we get into is the flags.
They get overwhelming.
And now the problems that we have is,
we don't use LaunchDarkly currently.
We use an open source software,
but there are overwhelming number of flags
and no one knows how to, you know,
which one to remove, which one to keep.
Is there kind of a governance
that you have in your teams?
- Yeah. And they solve for
that within the platform.
I should also say we're
not paid to be here.
It maybe it sounds like we were,
we're just fan boys,
like that we're, you know?
- We huge fan boys.
- Actually, they pay us
because they're customers.
- That's right.
That's right. Yeah.
- And so within the console,
they have a stale flag
module where you can go.
Any flag that hasn't been
called in three weeks
or something like that.
There you can set your parameters,
but there's specific
definitions for stale flags.
There's a dashboard where dev teams can
do that either every sprint,
review their stale flags, do that,
you know, every other, every third sprint,
build it into their workflow,
so that they're just reviewing
what flags are no longer getting called
so they can clean up that
tech debt along the way.
- Yeah. For us it's a combination of
the code references capability
that's in LaunchDarkly.
So you add GitHub action
that basically has LaunchDarkly
scan for feature flags
inside of the repo.
And then it reports that into the projects
inside of LaunchDarkly.
So you can go into a specific feature flag
and if you have got a flag
that's actually operating
across multiple repos,
you'll be able to see the
repos that it's used in.
And then you're able to
define how many lines of code
you wanna show inside of LaunchDarkly
where the feature flag is
to determine whether or not
it's actually something
that's safe to remove.
And then like you're saying,
there's a number of different affordances
within LaunchDarkly.
There's some default rules that exist
that look at flag evaluations,
time that the flag has been existing to,
and it will start to indicate,
oh, this is ready for code.
This flag is ready for code removal.
Oh, you've removed it from all the codes,
so now it's ready to archive.
And those affordances we can,
we take that and then we
provide that information
to the team so that they can go ahead
and build into their sprint plans
any sort of flag cleanup
operations that they need
to make sure that they take
care of to maintain hygiene.
- Yeah. We actually just
released a hygiene agent
at GitHub universe that will help
analyze that more automatically.
- Oh, I need to look at that. I love it.
- Yeah. And it came
from, again, as you know,
being around for over
a decade is, you know,
I used to see if you used
to search for feature flags,
the number one hit was an
article not written by me
that said feature flags
are the worst kind of technical debt.
And it was people who were using
some sort of home brew, homegrown solution
and they just were
accumulating so much crud
- Yep.
- of like stale broken flags
that nobody knew what to do anymore.
And it's like feature flags
are the worst kind of technical debt
if you're not managing them.
- Yep. There are, we've
found a couple use cases
for permanent feature flags though.
If, yeah,
let let's say, you know,
a key vendor goes down
and we have an outage in our website,
we have flags that can send
up a coach mark to say,
I'm sorry,
like we're experiencing
technical difficulties right now.
And so that flag's just always out there
and we just flip it on when we need to.
But for the most part
you're gonna want to clean up flags
once they're no longer being
evaluated on a regular basis.
- Yeah. We have some customers who,
if they're getting floods of traffic,
either from a denial service attack
or just something that could
just put up a graceful failure,
which is much better than
tire sites just collapsing.
- Yep.
- I think we have time
for one more question if there's anybody.
- [Audience member] Hi, sorry.
So my question was already asked,
so I have a different one now.
About the reliability of feature flags.
So the biggest concern that comes up
when thinking about LaunchDarkly
and discussing with the management
is not necessarily the cost,
'cause you can still
explain the cost benefits,
but the reliability on something
which is served from an
external third party server
to look at and say that,
okay, if this goes down,
then this was the last guardrail
that we had before everything
is displayed to the customer.
- Yeah. Maintaining flag
defaults is a big part of that.
And we're at the AWS conference,
last time we saw this was,
you know, was the USE outage
where there were two teams
who had not set their defaults
correctly and they went down.
You know, LaunchDarkly had some, you know,
they were in USE Swan,
they had some lessons learned outta that,
but the people who had
maintained their defaults,
even when AWS was down,
even when LaunchDarkly was
down, it worked flawlessly.
- It's a great question.
And you know, similar to that situation
where LaunchDarkly helps is having
different services like the relay service.
So the relay service acts
as almost like a middleware
to go back to central,
but at least it's caching a
set of all the flag variations.
So our tenants are actually
talking to that first
before they go back to
LaunchDarkly central.
Any changes that are coming from central
are basically being
brought down to that relay.
And then I think some of the
other protection mechanisms
that certainly helped us in
that experience was that,
when our users are
working with our platform,
there's local storage that's being used
where there's flag caching net,
that happens naturally.
So the reliability from a
user experience perspective
is just, from my perspective,
is something that is easily mitigated
by these different mechanisms
that LaunchDarkly has in place
or, you know, with a small sidecar
that you in install in your environment
that you can prevent those kinds of,
or at least you can for
a short period of time
you have some protection from that.
- Well, thank you very
much to Nate and Jeffrey.
This wasn't meant to be a vendor talk,
but thank you for describing
the product so well.
I appreciate it.
Can we give first,
if you have more questions,
we do have a booth on the
floor if you wanna visit it.
And can we please give
our panelists a big hand.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.